somebody's single oh she's gone I had a
question for her oh well
um okay we're gonna go around the table
on this actually we're not gonna go
around the table on this
um Zoe you had a viral video recently on
Tick Tock uh where you were giving some
dating advice what was the title of the
video uh
the first one yeah it was like dating
advice that no one
um
Common Sense dating advice that you
don't want to hear but you'd need to
hear right okay we were gonna pull it up
and watch it but unfortunately we can't
so um I hate hearing myself speak
sometimes so uh what I don't know if
you've committed it to memory but what
were the tips that you offered in that
first uh video I think the very first
one if someone wants to pull it up we
can just because like I've already made
like six of them we we can um so I would
say the very first one was uh let's see
like don't complain about cheating if
you're willing to stick around for it
you either shut up and move on and learn
how to work through it or leave
um
based yeah what does that mean bass it
just means like good is it okay I'm new
to the lingo I'm like what but I think
the one that pissed most people off is
that I said men have it harder in life
especially financially but I was talking
about this in dating a hundred percent I
feel like men and yes I know like my
um
what I compared it to I was like you
know like men can't just sit here and
bust their coochie open on of or 10
grand a month was a little biased
because it's literally my life but
um yeah I don't you want to go into that
why I think that men well first we will
go into that how about we go around the
table so
who has it harder when it comes to
dating men or women go ahead
I think it definitely does depend on the
situation
in general
amen okay
I think it depends on your standards but
in general in general man I think it's a
lot of pressure I think men 100 percent
that's so funny that everyone's saying
this now because the girl is in the
comment were calling me pick Misha
sprinkle sprinkles specific dating yeah
specific to dating man
yeah a lot of things
I think we both equally have it hard
men women both well I don't know if it's
equally have it hard I think women have
certain difficulties that perhaps men
don't have of course and men have
difficulties that women don't have
exactly I think generally speaking men
have a definitely a harder time with
dating um what about you what do you
think yeah see the men have a pretty
rough time if you if it like like you
have these guys in your comments asking
if they're being overlooked because
they're blue collar and now it becomes
this issue where and you you talk about
this and and actually you do too Brian
but a very small pool of men are the
ones that get all of the attention even
though there are lots of good
hard-working men who would love to find
somebody good and and have a
relationship but because women are The
Gatekeepers of sex they have to compete
and it's difficult and it can be really
discouraging and extremely lonely and
that's why like after it took me about a
week to make a response video to all the
girls in my comments being like pick me
pick me because I really I had to sit
down with a few of my girlfriends just
to make sure that like maybe my comment
was a little like [__] up maybe I
should like do some self-introspection
which is everything that I preach and
then I came down to it as I do feel like
in society especially when it comes to
dating we hold the power we hold the yes
or the nose right they don't really have
much say anymore which I mean that's
just the way the world Works around it
right now but I don't feel like we give
men enough compassion for the hardships
that they face like we love men
conditionally I don't I mean in my
relationship now is the first
relationship I've actually practiced
loving somebody
unconditionally so like when it comes to
like money and when it comes to like
dick size all this kind of [__] that
we're so like I don't love you unless
you have this yeah what about us and I
feel like a lot of women take this and
they're like okay cool you want this out
of a man but I I do not feel that the
question what do you bring to the table
is a bad question to ask because if all
you can bring me is that you have a fat
ass and you have a pretty face and you
can [__] good
that's gonna get the man but like how
are you gonna keep him hear what
substance that's the reason why I don't
I don't care about the oh she's just a
porn star and only fans girl no I'm
smart as [__] and half of the men that
can get that have gotten to know me can
all say the same thing like holy [__]
you're smart as hell like why are you
doing porn I'm like well because I'm
capitalizing off the market okay I'm
using my looks to capitalize
but I feel like a lot of women that I
meet which is the reason why 90 of my
friends are guys and I know it sounds I
know this is like feeding in some more
of the pikmi thing but
no I feel like men hold me accountable I
don't feel like a lot of women hold
themselves accountable and especially so
we're like always preaching these
standards and I'll say the same thing
for men I don't I don't do leftists I
don't do right I'm literally my [__] is
Middle Ground because I feel like women
preach these crazy standards that they
can't even upkeep themselves men preach
these crazy standards and like you know
like the whole men want a traditional
wife but they're not traditional no
matter 100 but I feel like women are
taking like you know when a man says oh
I don't want a girl with a high body
count we're like that man's trash he's
[__] no that's just his [__]
preference but then I feel like when
women say
um like oh you know I want I want a man
to make this this amount of money it's
not coming from a place if like she
knows who she is she's she's coming from
a place of like what Society is sort of
what they should once and men and men
are just precious
Hey look it's Pearl I like Pearl I just
got here thanks for the awesome content
one more time it's a really nice vibe to
enjoy a coffee to and fire up the
business much love Brie and panel Brie
huh
I feel like some
something that thank you Victor in that
same vein it's like it's never our fault
when things go wrong and that's
something that I see a lot when women
talk about different aspects of life
it's never if you pick if you pick
shitty guys it's never your fault if you
if you go into too much student debt
it's never your fault right if you don't
negotiate well when you're trying to get
a job it's never your fault and that
really hurts women because it doesn't
actually Empower us to take
any sort of agency over our own lives
and actually make decisions and be
responsible for our own actions but men
have to do that because if they do not
they are not attractive partners and
that's really an unfair standard that
our society has particularly in the US I
think that that's a real problem yeah
I mean that's just my sentiment about it
you know what I was thinking about which
is crazy if you're a one percent guy
like top one percent let's just say
height money looks whatever you can't
expect a virgin
like wait you can't or you can you can't
if you're a top one yeah like they don't
expect it I'm not saying they don't want
it but they don't expect it oh the top
guy yeah doesn't expect a virgin yeah
and that's like that's just kind of
speaks to the dating pool for like men
today you can get like to the top like
one percent of men and you don't expect
a virgin
I mean like what do men look for
typically historically Purity youth all
right attractiveness obviously pretty in
shape and so it's like you have a guy
that can get to like the Pinnacle of
what women want like you know tall
muscles money whatever and like those
guys don't expect a virgin because like
the quality of women has just gone down
today like the average partner count is
like what
I mean they say like between five and
eight
um and like
you know that after like five to seven
Partners your chance of a happy marriage
drops to like 20 in 10 years roughly
why though yeah if you're I mean why
does body count matter so [__] much I
mean I mean you're gonna find different
studies that
part of the reason that your chance of
having marriage go down is because you
have more experience and you know what
you want why and it is
in a relationship you know about it like
oh I mean I just wanna I just want to
ask like how is it working like how is
women having more Partners working in
society is it doing is it leading us to
having more fulfilling long happy
relationships or not because 100 years
ago we're getting the relationships
100 obviously a hundred years ago only
15 percent of women admitted to
premarital sex 85 percent of women
let's say they're a lot let's say
they're big liars and we double it okay
that's still two out of three that were
virgins on their wedding night and so
like my question is are relationships in
a better place today than they were at
100 years ago because say say what you
want about relationships a hundred years
ago you cannot tell me that the way
relationships are today are working like
half of our generation is afraid of
getting married because of what we've
seen in our parents yeah like that is a
horrible place to stay together because
they felt like they no they didn't our
parents are that's not true our parents
are the most no no I'm talking about
them about like generationally no for so
long women didn't have the autonomy to
say no and to ask for something I demand
what they want
and now women do they can say no I don't
want that I don't want you you don't
make me happy I want what makes me happy
okay and that's why I think that is that
what a relationship down no I think it
goes both ways 100 I think the man gets
to say no that doesn't make me happy but
the thing is it was only one-sided for
so long I want to look at what outcomes
have women had so not like personally
anecdotally this is just in society what
outcomes has this led to one in three
women have had an abortion one in three
women have an STD 90 of women have been
uncontraceptives at one point in their
life women are on antidepressants more
than ever before what has promiscuity
led to why are women magnifying us
well why can't we why can't we have a
conversation about women without saying
but men like we're just talking about
the women now so we can come back to the
men later I'm not saying men are perfect
but I'm saying like if if we're so happy
and promiscuity leads to great things
why is it when our body counts go up
where we have more STDs more abortions
we're on antidepressants more like it's
not good I heard the president has
anything to do you don't body count yeah
I personally don't think that it's just
like oh yeah you should just [__]
Whoever Whenever at any time you want
just legs wide open anyone can get it I
don't think that that's necessarily
healthy but I do think that it is your
it's your life and your decision if you
if I want to have more than one sexual
partner in my life that's it I haven't
and it hasn't what like on that topic
let me just come in here for a sec Pearl
um if you want to have more than one
sexual partner at a time uh what's the
most you've had at one time oh at one
time I don't think I've ever had more
than one oh well then what are you
arguing for no I mean in my life like if
I don't want to only ever have sex
thank you man appreciate it now that the
US government has admitted that UFOs are
reasons we are about a year while I'm
admitting non-human intelligence is real
and has visited us would you date
outside your race alien oh
helium
[Music]
would you date outside
what choice do we got I would I would
definitely [__] an alien I would so
[__] alien but like if it was a
humanoid alien you know but if it was
like some [__]
weird looking yeah if it was like
humanoid alien I'm down
she has no Poker Face I'm just picturing
some kind of like giant spider with like
[__]
yeah I can't picture aliens
like a blue app like the blue Avatar
Avatar that's not how I [__]
connected
I need my extensions back y'all bro
turbo you you wyling
um who here would let's say it's like an
alien but it it kind of looks like a
human like human shape and it's like got
parts and [__] but
oh it's got like some weird I don't know
I mean if it's hot and you'd [__]
Avatar oh hell yeah you're here with
[__] an avid the navi I think they're
called yeah I don't know
I don't know I need to see this
interactive like if he was cool if the
alien was cool
you're all about the vibe
okay all right I got it okay wow that
was an interesting one okay we were
talking about
um you said you've only dated one person
at the time yeah
word there's never been any crossover no
I actually it it like really stresses me
out even when it comes so your friends
are throwing you under the bus you just
laughed at you it's been like three days
you don't even know me that well that
one does okay so you're saying that
maybe there's like Chaz
on Sunday and Gustavo really stresses me
out to try and juggle relationships so I
really try to avoid it just one at a
time yeah in a 72-hour period what's the
most amount of guys that you've like
ever ever hooked up with in a 72 hour
period of time three days
I think too too
is she telling the truth yes I think so
you think so I'm like yeah I contradict
what you just said yeah but I when I was
saying like sexual partners I'm a more
like relationship wise like if I am
involved with someone I don't want to be
involved with anybody else
like I can't speak for everybody
um I've had my nights where I got a
little too [__] up and made poor
decisions
um what about in the Fortnight what's
the most important in the Fortnight it's
like 14 days
clarify the 2 and 72 hours was it 48
Hours yeah
yeah was it 24 hours was it seven hours
was it one hour
both at the same time or one right after
the other
just take me out oh what just a minute
I'm in the threesome that's something
it would I think it would be worse if it
was like one and then like 30 minutes
later other dude you might as well just
say yeah okay
well in terms of like the scale of like
sexual ethics and morality which is
uh whatever I feel like a threesome you
think a threesome is better than I think
a threesome would be better than back to
back I
I don't disagree like because they know
they know like because the second dude
is just like
just you know what I mean
it's Haram Pearl um wait so but what
about the Fortnight what's the most in
the fortnite and we're going around the
table on this one so get ready
come on three yeah okay
Kiana kumani
14 days
four score and seven years ago how many
people I've slept with in 14 days yeah
we're in the porn industry what do you
mean a lot that's not fair civilian like
cities oh civilians civilians
YouTube I think three three yeah well I
yeah in the 70s how much in the 72 hour
period
and then a fortnight two two and three
two
for both or for just one I think two
yeah two for 72 hours it was two and
then well I was pissed at the first one
so I kind of got back at him a good time
it was only two
okay if you say so um
wait so
Counting
Johnny Sins
how much or sorry not like just with the
porn industry including in 14 days I've
had
I've had five shoots in 14 days before
and one of those shoots was
um uh threesome so seven word okay
um what about you what's the most in 72
hours
I mean I think three and three three and
three yeah 72 and Fortnight what about
you one
for both yeah okay byronique what's up
none honey I had no dicks since uh
September
I never had no Fortnight whatever our
toys are tired nothing
all right
rip okay um
like how many how many people you've
hooked up with within a 72 hour period
throughout your whole life and then also
a 14-day period
throughout my whole life I've already
been over this I don't know my number
are you talking about like my back in a
72 hour period
um like in 72 hours yeah like at the
most uh probably two wait uh chat really
quick wait two minutes unless you're
talking about threesomes because I
wasn't a polyamorous relationship with a
female at one point in my life and that
was the last relationship I was in sure
okay yeah oh by the way chat can you let
me know did flan life gift 50 did he
gift 50 because if so we need to do a
foot check did we get a 50 gifted chat
hello
um okay and so in a fortnight two how
many three no I said I said if we're are
we counting threesomes because I had an
ex-girlfriend sure okay because because
I had an ex-girlfriend we um we had a we
had a threesome
um with well it's still it's still the
same girl so do I count the same girls
wise no no no no just just one time okay
because yeah and then still too okay we
can skip Michaela because
yeah
um
uh one I've only ever been with my
husband so really yeah okay I highly hey
I highly recommend it yeah
you're waiting I would highly recommend
it highly recommend it really stressful
otherwise
so you said so like I don't know I think
my 72 hours and then 14. I was like 19 I
had to force them with three girls in
the back of my Honda Civic and then I
don't know so I say 75 hours probably
like [__] five I was so young okay
that's some [__] twister we're all
really skinny oh we were drunk and [__]
there were some in the front some in the
back it was great how do you comfortably
eat it it was not comfortable we were
drunk as [__] I don't even know if we
did it correctly I just know that
somebody was falling out of the window
yeah somebody got
together yeah the sun room which is
right in the sunroom
two weeks
um
Archduke Franz Ferdinand back there do
you want to answer this
in the fortnight
14 days
you sure about that yeah okay
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible